Speaker 1: Well, my friends, there's been a
terribly tragic accident in Russia where a
Russian official who criticized Putin's invasion
of Ukraine has been found dead after accidentally
falling out of a window in the very hospital where
he was receiving treatment for an illness. It's
just a terribly tragic accident that absolutely
no one believes is an accident. It's another one
of these bizarre situations. Reuters reports
top Russian Oil Official Dies After Fall From
Hospital Window. From a hospital window. Reveal
Magana of the chairman of Russia's second largest
oil producer. Lukoil died Thursday earlier today
after falling from a hospital window in Moscow,
becoming the latest in a series of businessmen to
meet with sudden unexplained deaths. The sources
confirmed reports by several Russian media that
the 67 year old plunged to his death in unclear
circumstances. To people who knew him well said it
was highly unlikely he committed suicide. Another
source close to the company said there was belief
inside Lukoil management that he killed himself,
but he had not seen evidence or documents to
support that. When Moscow police were asked, Are
you investigating this as a suspicious death, they
said, We'll talk to the investigative committee.
The committee didn't say anything. Lukoil said
in a statement. Magana passed away following a
serious illness. Well, that's very different.
You know, you're sick in bed and you want some
fresh air. You get up to open the window to get
some fresh air and you trip over, I don't know,
your IV line or a banana peel, and next thing
you know, you fall out the window to your death.
That doesn't sound right. Several other senior
executives with ties to Russia's energy industry
have died suddenly in clear circumstances in the
past few months. The day after Russia sent forces
into Ukraine, a Gazprom executive was found
dead in his garage near Saint Petersburg. Hmm.
In April, Sergei Proto, senior top manager of
Russia's largest liquefied natural gas producer,
Novatek, was found dead with his wife and daughter
in Spain. Hmm. In May, Russian media reported a
former LUKOIL manager, Alexander Coubertin,
was found dead in a basement of a house.
And the same month, Russian media said Vladislav
Akayev, an ex vice president of Gazprom Bank,
was also found dead in a moscow apartment
with the bodies of his wife and daughter.
Hmm. I don't know about that. Unusual
among Russian companies. Lukoil took
a stand over Moscow's intervention
in Ukraine. They expressed concern
over the tragic events and called for the
soonest possible end to armed conflict. Ah,
well, that starts to get a little suspicious,
doesn't it? Now, some of you might be wondering,
why do these people. Let's be honest. Why do they
keep getting killed in the same way? Doesn't that
make it too obvious? Well, that's the point. It's
not that they're out of ideas. The idea here is
you send a message. If people really believed that
these were accidents, then the threat that you
might get killed, even if you're powerful just for
opposing the Putin regime. It doesn't come across.
It doesn't have the power and the weight that
it does. That's the whole point. This accident
that always looks the same. Oh, you know what?
They shot themselves in the back four times.
They fell out of a window and then stabbed
themselves a dozen times. You get the absurdity
of it. The fact that it is so absurd is the
entire point. And it creates this environment
where some critics choose not to speak out. And
it's Putin's Russia. It's Putin's Russia is what
it is. And no tragic accident, I think we can
say, with almost complete and total certainty.